please
hq
hey rangers good uh don't mind the mess
we're still settling in
of course let's see if we can find what
you want
oh
gonna be ashamed to blow it off
he's talking
[ __ ] baby
oh [ __ ] that's easy now cousins before
go on rangers tell us how sorry you are
[ __ ] you caught my butt i'm gonna peel
off an inch of your skin for every tear
i shed over the you taunt me god says
it's time for the skinning knife
don't listen to that oh yeah okay sorry
erastus cowards traitors are past aids
calculate come on you ain't seen the
last to me
you butchers
thanks for the help strangers in all our
years we we're the whose bible you
strangers saved our whole family from
those bushwhackers
desert rangers well that's a new tell
you what we ain't got much money but
we've got more bullets stashed than
we'll ever need that ain't near enough
for saving our lives but any questions
okay let's hear them
ship that getting alice their home
i remember him
nice fella he always helps train me to
shoot touch that rifle
tell me you're not about to start
trouble with a couple of 80 year olds
because that's where i draw the line
what can we do for you friends
mostly i have broccoli
oh i thought the 100 we're old enough to
remember if you're you're always welcome